[Applause]
are very strong as you know and even
though the speaker of the house is not
irish
italian-american i don't have irish
grandparents but i do have irish
grandchildren
shawn ryan
and leo
and again uh they are just an example of
the millions of bonds between our two
countries of irish americans and that
future
of our country is strengthened by
america's
if we talk about the firm commitment to
our future uh it's it's enhanced by
irish americans
the um
irish americans have fought in the
revolutionary war
and civil war have built our country in
so many ways i don't need to go into you
all know it it's the stories of your
life and always to make a peaceful
beautiful future for america i do want
to say that uh
in our shared history peace has been a
focal point and last night i mentioned a
good friday accords as a part of peace
in our time
[Applause]
i spoke about it last night because i
had the privilege of being on a number
of codels to ireland to northern ireland
as well and many of us who visit
northern ireland in the 90s saw at the
border tanks soldiers union jenks barbed
wire and the rest
and those of us who went recently
to observe the anniversary
of the good friday accord saw a
completely different situation at the
border
just a yellow line turning into a white
mine
making the distinction between northern
and southern and northern and
northern ireland and ireland what was
interesting mr president at that time
the speaker at stormont he gave a big
reception for us all children
all children high school aged children
and two of them spoke one catholic one
protestant and they both had the same
message they said that they who had
never known conflict
they made it clear they weren't going
back
nearly two generations of children
living in peace again we're sorry the
teacher could not be with us today i
commanded him last night and i just want
to say uh if he were here uh
what i said last night that we i had the
privilege of giving him and the bad
distinguished ambassador accepted on his
part and gave his rousing speech thank
you mr ambassador
he was oh and the british investors here
as well
[Applause]
i said at the time of the tea shop that
the world has been awed uh by his
handling of the pandemic because he's
had a lifetime
of leadership in terms of public health
his handling of
the economy of ireland especially during
the difficult times of brexit
his reinvigoration of the government
focus on housing and healthcare
healthcare being a focus
in his of public life and his unyielding
belief in the power of education for the
irish children
and we saluted him for iris ireland's
very important role in promoting peace
in ukraine
peace in ukraine
now in the spirit of peace and our
nation's long-time partnership let us
hear a blessing offered by wright
reverend thomas o'connor of our lady of
glass blast and bro abby in hickam
massachusetts is that your parish
[Applause]
reverend o'connor
good afternoon
[Music]
let us pray
oh awesome god
we come here today to commemorate saint
patrick who work to
unite and reconcile people
the same mission which all leaders of
nations are charged with
st patrick is remembered for his
simplicity
and pastoral care
for his humble trust in god
and for his fearless preaching of the
gospel
to those who had enslaved him in his
youth
he saw a future of ireland and the care
of its people as a core of his mission
he was committed to the growth of people
by building community
by teaching the people about christian
faith
about listening to god
like patrick we of irish ancestry have
been blessed with a captivating culture
which speaks to
speak of
who we are and what makes us irish
like an exquisite
landscape imbued with 40 shades of green
like irish soda bread and the endless
cups of tea
like a caylee celebration of
storytelling singing music in the beat
of the bull run
an irish step dancing
and the presence of guinness and jameson
are only an irish jig away
lies the gift of the gab present in the
irish and many politicians
present company is no exception
regardless if you have kissed the wiring
stone or not
like the gift of poetry
literature
mystics and myth
and as and also like the beautiful
concept of adam kara
soul friends
which our two nations have become over
the years
in a strong bond of hope
unity and trust
god we ask your blessing upon all those
who are gathered here
upon this food we are about to partake
of those who have prepared it and will
serve it
we ask your blessing also on those who
have less than we do
especially the children our nations
going to get hungry tonight
and dear god
we are particularly mindful of the
exiled people of the ukraine
who are in need of hope
and peace
healing
and safe passage
we ask all these in the name of the god
of abraham
the god of isaac
and the god of jacob
amen
[Applause]
do you think father has kissed the
barney stone
hey
oh well i haven't even been to ireland
yet
my father i've been to ireland i've
spoken to the doyle
big honor
to talk about the children and uh when
ronald reagan's came to
speak at that first luncheon he talked
about the children he said america has
been blessed by her irish children
and one of those irish children is now
the president of the united states
my wish for all of you is that you could
have been there last night and many of
you were
to hear the president
take pride in his irish american
heritage
he made us cry almost he made us laugh
in our hearts
and he made us think
he made a better think about what
america is and what america what the
irish community means to our great
country
and we could see how this great
president came to be
as a person
who understands the beautiful diversity
of our country as i've said
because he respects his own heritage
he understands how we accept we respect
our own heritage as well
and he understands the dignity and worth
of all people because his irish heritage
in his case was accompanied by a deep
catholic faith
he talks about his mother and father
quite a bit
and
keep don't keep the faith spread the
faith right is that your mom
that's your mom
so again i i think of another irish
president when i think
of president biden and i've told him
this
when i was young i was in school and i
was attended the kennedy inaugurations
many of you heard me say this
and everybody in the world practically
but certainly in our country ever since
knows what president kennedy said about
ask not to citizens of america ask not
what america can do you know that that
whole sentence
but the very next sentence and i say
this to the president the very next
sentence
president kennedy made this statement
thinking of joe biden
to the citizens to the people of the
world
ask not what america can do for you but
what we can do working together for the
freedom of mankind
and that is exactly what our president
is doing working together with respect
for everyone of the other countries
not in any condescending way or anything
but in a respectful
collaboration
that sentence was made for you mr
president at this time
when we were many of us in in munich to
the
security conference we heard leaders of
countries and
foreign ministers defense ministers but
heads of state right you shaking your
head say thank you for your president
for bringing us together for reinforcing
the transatlantic alliance and then even
beyond that
and for helping us work together to help
the people of ukraine in a way that is
unifying and not dictating and so again
with great pride it's my pleasure
to bring to one of america's children
that god has blessed us with the
president of the united states
oh
[Applause]
father uh before i begin
bless me father from about to sin
well i just want you to know i may be
irish but i'm not stupid i married
dominic giacopa's daughter
look uh thank you very much nancy for
that very gracious and
very over-the-top introduction i
appreciate very much
you know uh i just got off the on the
way up before i came up here i was on
the
zoom as we say with the t-shirt for
about 45 minutes
and he is he's looking well he feels
well
he's tested positive but he feels well
it looks good and uh
he wanted to uh i know the ambassador is
here to bring in regards but uh he is uh
he's really sorry he can't be here and
he was looking forward to it as was his
wife
you know
the um
the good spirits and feelings
as well
that exist on st patrick's day uh seems
to be uh one of those few times uh
and not well not so i would say a few we
should have more times like this where
democrats and republicans get together
and we actually not only
agree on one thing but we remind
ourselves we actually like each other
and it's a useful thing
and
[Applause]
you know uh
yates wrote and i quote
talent perceives differences
genius unity
talents perceives
differences genius unity
and you know i think today we can
add a fifth item to uh
at least my unity agenda and that's
support of our relationship between
ireland and the united states which is
taking on
an even more intense and cooperative
form than it ever has
because of
ireland's
neutrality
on this issue
it brings together speaker pelosi
leader mccarthy uh richie neal who is uh
irish as we say where i come from from
belt buckle to shoe soul
and uh
and the leaders of both our parties and
all the friends of iowa
i uh you know uh
i i'm the
proud son of catherine eugenia finning
invite and uh
like so many americans have already
shared it's i love ireland and
i was raised in a circumstance where you
would have fought my whole family none
of they came in 1844 and 1845
but you'd think they'd all lived in
ireland the last 60 years
previous 60 years
the um
there's uh as i was talking to taoiseach
today uh
the irish on st patrick's day i think
the irish americans think they're more
irish than the irish
and uh but that's kind of how i was
raised like so many americans of
irish heritage like other people of
other heritage as well
uh i was uh it was imbued in me to be
proud of uh
proud of my uh my heritage and uh
you know uh
pride that
was passed down generations in our
family even though they've been here
since the
mid-1800s
and uh it was this part of the year we
breed especially up in scranton
and uh where we live with my you know my
grandpa
my grandfather ambrose finnegan used to
saying i mean this he'd say joey if
you're lucky enough to be irish you're
lucky enough
every time something bad having to go i
don't wear head i'm not sure
anyway
but because of being an irish family
uh family was everything my dad's
expression was families the beginning
the middle of the end
and he
but you know uh
the faith we share with one another and
the resilience that
we've all gone through both in america
and in ireland uh you know uh
are ones that we've been knocked down
sometimes just knocked flat on our back
and uh
my my mom's expression for real was joey
get up
just get up
get up the simple proposition it was
sort of the irish evidence you just get
up
no matter what
dust yourself off and move not we're not
the only culture that has that view but
it was imbued
in my family and
the other one was that and i mean
sincerely my dad is
no one is better than you and you're no
better than anyone else
not a joke no one is better than you
you know better than anyone else
and it's real
it's real
because we were taught never my mother
would say never bow never bend never
healed
but the truth of the matter was that
in the days when
my parents and grandparents were growing
up in this coal country of scranton
being irish was less than a badge of
honor
my
my great grandfather
blew it
my on my grandmother finnigan's maiden
name
was only the second catholic ever
elected to the uh senate in the state of
uh in the state of pennsylvania
and that was 1907.
only the second one the first one was in
i think 1838 or 1840.
the point was that like many cultures
like many folks
uh
where you came from was either viewed as
an asset or a liability
and uh where uh
you know but the point is that
everything
that we were taught and i'm sure all of
you of irish background and other
backgrounds as well
we're taught that
that you know it's all about striving
for a better future
that you can do better just simply do
better
and uh you know and you can do it while
you cherish the past
now you have to forget the past or just
or just
disassociate yourself from it but
cherish it
you know these are the values of
immigrants not only from ireland but
from uh like my great-great-grandparents
when they were brought here brought
themselves united states but today it's
only part of what it means to be irish
there's a
indelible part of it that is american
because the values are the same
in my view
the values built into our constitution
that we are the i i verbally say last
night i think we're the most unique
country in the history of the world
we're the only country
based upon organizationally not
geography not ethnicity not not race not
religion
but on
a notion an idea
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men and women are created equal
endowed by their creativity with certain
inalienable rights life liberty i mean
that's the basis of why we formed this
country
no other country
has ever been based on a notion like
that they've incorporated those notions
but the basis for the organization
has been their ethnicity their religion
their geography whatever but not here
and i know i say it and many of you say
and i think people wonder whether we
really mean it
i really think the source of our
strength is our diversity
the source of our strength is our
diversity
and uh you know the values that uh
immigrants from ireland brought and but
as i said they're not only
they're not only irish values the values
i think are the vast majority of
immigrants who come to the united states
and i'm proud to say that the bond
between ireland united states by the way
has grown deeper and stronger
over the years
for real
and we've navigated a once in a century
pandemic together we've grieved
of too many people in both our countries
and we work to rebuild our economies and
taking on the challenge of renewing and
strengthening our democracy because
again i apologize for repeating myself
but i know many of you heard me
say i think we're in an inflection point
in history
i think and i mean that sincerely it
occurs every several generations
i think we're in a genuine struggle
between autocracies and democracies
and whether or not democracies can be
sustained
and i'm going to be speaking to
president xi tomorrow he'll remind me
that i told him he remembers every damn
thing i've said unfortunately
but all kidding aside
we talked about the idea he that he does
not believe about democracy he's going
to be sustained in the 21st century
because things move so rapidly
technology's changing so much
democracies don't have time to arrive at
consensus that's why autocracies will
succeed
well you know now you know we uh
you have ireland stepping up
not only in terms of their relationship
with us but
uh you know the good friday agreements
build on political and economic progress
that we've made together
and uh i know some criticized me but i i
have a good relationship
with the prime minister of great britain
boris
um always kid each other we see each
other but the point is that uh
i've made it clear that i don't think i
just speak for myself the good friday
agreements are firmly firmly firmly
firmly supported here in the united
states and we insist that it occur they
can be maintained
[Applause]
people in northern ireland have made
significant changes as well
there's movement as you've mentioned the
young kids you talked about
protestant and catholic
talking how i mean how they've never
known anything but being able to get
along
i remember the first time
i uh
on my parents 50th wedding anniversary
my brothers and sister we got together
and gave my
and we can work something out for your
father we gave my parents a trip to
ireland
and
but
coincided i was going over the storm on
talks
and so they said you take him joey
and
but the point is that uh
it was it was a bit of an epiphany for
my parents
uh they thought they hear all the
stories from their ancestors about this
that the other thing some of it
apocryphal some of it real
but uh it was uh it was really amazing
but when we took them to the north
it was interesting we went up to uh the
storm and anyway
it was an interesting thing to watch
to watch the look on my mother's face
and my father's face as we
toured ireland to see both the things
that they had heard
that were consistent with what this
third because you never know
you know there's an exaggeration about
what this happened
they came back uh
more hopeful than they had been
as opposed to and that was a while ago
my generic point is that you know
now you have ireland and uh great
britain
and uh you know the republic
uh standing together against a murderous
dictator a pure thug who is waging an
immoral war against the people of
ukraine
and by the way
the republic is paying a big price for
this
a big number for supporting the strategy
for supporting the sanctions including
aircraft a whole range of things it's
not a minor contribution they're making
to this effort
is significant
ireland united states are working
together
for the first time now they're on the
united nations security council
ireland's a part of the security council
now
and the european union and putin is
paying a a big price for his aggression
and uh and they are part of the reason
this cost is going so high
that's a little you know everybody talks
about germany having stepped up and
changed their notions about being more
more leaning forward but and they have
well so is ireland
so was ireland a neutral country
ireland has stepped up
and taking the hit for what they're
doing
and you look uh you know ladies and
gentlemen the relationship between
ireland and the united states is a
dynamic and i think essential
partnership that
as much as it has ever been
and uh you know it's sustained and
strengthened by the friends of ireland
in this room and all across the country
and uh
you know the connections that link our
people stretch back through history and
they forward well forward future you
know as
we uh we share a common goal a future of
a greater peace greater hope greater
security
and a greater sense of uh who we are as
a country
and you know uh i
my uh my mother's expression
got it from her
grandfather was
you know as long as you're alive
you have an obligation to strive
and you're not dead till you've seen the
face of god
that's what i think of when i think of
ireland
all the troubles they've been through
they have never ever ever quit
never ever ever ever quit
not once
they've gotten up
and now they're beginning to at least
have the benefits of all the hard work
and labor they've engaged in
and becoming a real actor mr ambassador
on the world stage and at the united
nations
and uh so
i want to thank you mr ambassador and i
and i thank the teacher today
and uh i uh
i just i
should probably tell you that uh my
mother when i took when we went to
ireland
and we were
were in the south and
my father
was a real gentleman and uh
his greatest regret was he never had a
college education
but if i were if you were any one of you
were coming back to delaware with me and
my dad were around and retired
and i didn't call him to tell him i was
bringing you over and introduced him so
he had a chance to put on a coat and a
tie
because he would only see you that way
that was my dad
and as we were going to ireland with
trail was the what was it was a t-shirt
and we walked in to have a picture taken
and my dad had this brand new blazer
that had a
a a
patch on my my brother-in-law jack owens
who's irish from
like you neil uh and uh
it was this patch just this crest
and that's latin written on and i never
took the time to look at it although i
had to take four years of latino three
through three years in latin and the
catholic high school i went to
and uh
and the t-shirt were having my picture
taken he said oh mr biden he said i
agree
and what had said latin don't let the
bastards get you down
well we can't let them get us down
we can't let them get us down
thank you for allowing me to come back
home
come up here and speak and
thank you nancy nice compliments
[Applause]
[Applause]
mr president this is a toast that i
learned from my grandchildren i've said
it to our colleagues here before
that goes like this
it's an irish toast
thing is that no one can hear you
dance is that no one can see you
love as if you've loved never loved
before and live as if heaven is on earth
so when i said to them is that a toast
that is a tradition in the connelly
family they say no
that's a sign that is in the shannon
airport
well my grandmother had one he said may
those who love us love us and those who
don't may they turn their ankles so we
know they're coming by their land
[Applause]
thank you